We want to end up with an equation for the total weight of the suitcase. And we
know that, that is y. So, I'll start by writing y equals something, something
that we need to figure out. Well, the total weight needs to equal the weight of
the suitcase itself, and then also the weight of the glasses wipers that Grant
puts in it. However, we know that the weight of the empty suitcase is just 7
pounds. So, we can just substitute in 7 in that slot in the equation. The total
weight of all the wiper sets will just be equal to the weight of one wiper set,
which is 0.5 pounds, times the number of wiper sets packed, which is x. So, we
can substitute that into our equation as well. And in the end, we have y equals
7 plus 0.5 x.